if you think that your thoughts have
something to do with your future just
from a theoretical standpoint that your
thoughts Create Your Destiny and you
think sixty to seventy thousand thoughts
in one day and ninety percent of those
thoughts are the same thoughts as the
day before well then your life isn't
going to change very much as long as
you're thinking the same way and those
same thoughts lead to the same choices
the same choices lead to the same
behaviors the same behaviors create the
exact same experiences and we anticipate
the same feelings or emotions from those
experiences and those emotions are the
payoff that drive our very same thoughts
while our biology our neural circuitry
neurochemistry our hormones and even our
gene expression will be equal to how we
think how we act and how we feel and how
we think how we act and how we feel is
called our personality and our
personality creates our personal reality
that's it so the present personality
who's listening to this show has created
the present personal reality called
their life so if you can latch on to
this idea if you want to create a new
life a new personal reality you got to
change your personality which means you
better start thinking about what you've
been thinking about and changing it you
begin to become conscious of your
unconscious actions or habits or
behaviors and modify them and then we
have to begin to look at the emotions
that we live by every single day that
keep us connected to the past and decide
do these emotions belong in our future
need motivation watch the top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
Joe dispenza and my take on his top 10
rules of success enjoy
most people are trying to create a new
personal reality as the same personality
and it doesn't work you literally have
to become someone else so the principle
of Neuroscience says that nerve cells
that fire together wire together you
keep thinking the same way making the
same choices demonstrating the same
habits that creating the same
experiences that stamp the same networks
of neurons into the same patterns all
for the familiar feeling called you and
you do that for 10 years on end you're
going to begin to hardwire certain
patterns in your brain that becomes your
identity and by the time we're 35 years
old it kind of becomes fixed right and
psychology used to say that you can't
change that but we now know that you can
so then that kind of box in the brain
that is the habit of ourselves it's uh
we're 95 of the time running a series of
programs so then sitting and doing the
work we have to become disentangled from
those programs and so the moment you
decide to do something differently or
make a new choice but most people don't
want to face is that discomfort and that
that discomfort that that uncertainty
that lack of predictability the that
that that unknown is what people are
afraid of because they'd rather live in
guilt at least they can predict who
they're going to be then take a chance
and possibility so when a person begins
to understand this and you say well how
long have you been this way and they say
I've been like this for 35 years and you
say why 35 years because 35 years ago I
had this one event well the stronger the
emotion you feel from the reaction from
that event the more altered you feel
inside of you the more the brain Narrows
its focus and freezes the image and
takes a snapshot and that's called a
memory right so then forget the memory
just overcome the emotion because it's
the emotion that keeps you anchored to
the past so that sounds really good
theoretically but when you step out into
that unknown into that void
the body really is in a habit and what a
habit is when the body becomes the mind
or if you're thinking about that past
event and it's producing an emotion well
you need an image and a feeling to start
the conditioning process so the body's
either conditioned into the familiar
past or it's hardwired in the
predictable future because it wakes up
every single day and runs through the
same series of routine actions so the
present moment then becomes the unknown
when people start feeling that
discomfort today they'd rather get on
their cell phone and call someone or get
up and say I can't meditate or you know
I have too much to do they excuse
themselves they return back into that
familiar feeling because the body's
actually telling the brain The Habit is
when the body becomes the mind so the
body stepping out into the unknown and
says ooh I'd rather feel guilty I'd
rather feel unhappy then be in this this
comfort so then at least then when they
return back to that familiar feeling
then they feel safe so they step out in
the unknown and the body starts
influencing the mind saying you can
start tomorrow you're too busy it's your
mother's fault you know it's your
culture's fault I don't have enough
money this isn't going to work
those are the programs in there that are
standing in the way between you and your
future so then nerve cells that no
longer fire together no longer wire
together so the act of observing those
states of Mind and Body
means you're no longer the program
you're the Consciousness observing that
program so so then
to meditate it means to become familiar
with so as you become familiar with
those thoughts you become conscious of
how you speak you become aware of how
you act you notice how you're feeling
the more conscious you become of those
unconscious programs the less
unconscious you'll go in your waking day
why because it's not enough to just have
a great meditation and get up and get on
the freeway and get in traffic and
getting stressed you just return back to
the old self again our job then
is to sustain that modified State of
Mind and Body the entire day and if you
can get ready because something
different or unusual is going to begin
to happen in your life and it will come
as a coincidence or a synchronicity and
that's breadcrumbs from the Divine
saying you're on the path just keep
doing it there'll be another one just
keep staying in that energy and so
teaching people then to understand that
there's a formula that we now know that
if you apply that formula you'll begin
to see those changes and now as people
are doing it more and more
effectively the results are going up as
well we just had Bond University they
just took a whole bunch of my brain
scans from 10 years ago
huge clinical study a lot of analysis
and and they're Blown Away by the speed
in which the community can change brain
or heart coherence they they know how to
do it it's not
something that's that's separate from
them they've practiced it enough times
that they they now know how to do it so
what's the significance of that well
really simple in your life
if you start returning back to the same
reactions to the same people and
circumstances you're returning back to
the old self so you got to stay
conscious in your life and and if you're
not being defined by a vision of the
future then you're left with the
memories of the past and you will be
predictable in your life so Crossing
that River of change from the old self
to the new self there's a neurological
biological chemical hormonal a genetic
death of the old self but if you teach
people there's something on the other
side they won't give up on themselves
they'll keep going so there's enough
evidence to encourage people and you
can't tell me you're too old to do this
work you can't tell me you're too sick
to do this work you can't tell me you
had a turbulent past or or that you're
too overweight or too underweight or too
out of shape or you can't even tell me
that you've never meditated before in
fact some of our greatest
scans or people who just have never
meditated before that are not trying to
do anything they just follow
instructions so
our community now is beginning to
understand that it is possible and they
go all in not 50 in not 60 and when we
do a week-long event we got a thousand
people or 1500 people and they are all
in and that when they start getting
Beyond themselves that first day or
second day once they start getting
Beyond themselves and that magic starts
to happen then I have no idea I can't
predict what's going to happen next and
it's usually pretty pretty exciting Rule
Number Two Step into the unknown we do
have beliefs that feel good to us
because those beliefs are based on past
experiences and those emotions keep us
attached to the belief chemically it's
in our biology and we tend to think
neurologically and feel chemically
within experiences then that are
connected to the past so when our
beliefs are challenged we hold on to the
emotion like Jesus had a brother what
that doesn't feel right you know he was
married to Mary Magdalene you know I
mean people freak out because they've
been conditioned and they want to hold
on to that because that then ensures a
future that they can rely on
when you step out of your belief systems
and stepping into the unknown
you are now leaving behind your past and
then so then do you have the faculty
and the ability to create do you have
that ability if not because then in
order for you to go from that Old belief
to a new belief then you better have a
plan and you better be willing to have a
new experience that is no longer a
wishy-washy belief
it has to be a very strong impression in
your biology it comes with an
accompanying experience
that then changes your biology to
understand you believe something else
but that's not the end either because
then you have the question from that
point
what is the next belief that helps you
to understand the next thing for example
let's talk about it on two levels and
time out here for a second I don't care
we can go to 11 30 here oh beautiful
thank you so much it was a good
conversation so think about this
the person in our work
who I'll use a simple example
has a very very difficult marriage and
her marriage falls apart her husband was
abusive
and lived by the stress hormones for
extended period of time of course all
our energy is going for some threat in
our external environment she has no
energy in him her internal environment
for growth and repair no energy for
long-term building projects the the body
is in vigilance it's it's always anxious
she's anticipating something bad
happening all the time and she's got
food allergies to
everything
she's allergic to her environment
she comes to the event she does the work
it takes her three months and all of a
sudden in one event she has a
breakthrough and she's eating anything
she wants now she's changed her belief
about her past because she's no longer
saying I am this way because of my
relationship with my husband see because
when you say I am this way because I had
an abusive father I am this way because
I had a difficult marriage I am this way
because I got fired from my job what
you're saying is I haven't changed since
that event emotionally and so now you're
viewing your future through the lens of
the past when you overcome that
emotional state a memory without the
emotional charge is called wisdom
now you're ready to create a new future
because if you're still attached to the
emotion you're still attached to the
past and you can't create a future so
all of a sudden now the person has a
transformation
she had a shift she knows that she knows
that she's liberated from that anxiety
she's she feels it and as a result of it
in a matter of moments Ben or biology
reorganizes to a new mind and now she's
I'm watching her eat pizza I'm watching
her eat a hamburger she's laughing she's
and it's and it's sustained
but that's not the end because if she
healed herself then the next question is
I understand the physics and biology of
what I've done is it possible if I heal
myself
but I can heal another person
now my my belief is being challenged
again now I'm challenging my current
belief is it possible well I don't know
I haven't had the experience yet but if
I'm thinking it and I understand the
semantic philosophical theoretical
intellectual information can I initiate
it can I apply it can I personalize it
can I demonstrate it can I modify my
behavior in some way based on my last
experience to have a more evolved
experience and that more evolved
experience will be outside of my beliefs
currently but I understand the science
and if I can get my behaviors to match
my intentions and I've done it to myself
and quantum physics says is that
Consciousness is non-local will help if
I can create a coherent signature here I
should be able to do it in another
person
so then when the when the experience
occurs
now I have more circuitry in my brain
that's enriched I have a new feeling in
my body and I feel like a Healer I
already feel like a Healer because I've
healed myself but let me see if I can
heal someone else I'm going to bring up
that emotion and it may take me a few
times and I'm telling you that woman we
did a coherent session where we're
healing another person and the person
laying down there was a woman who from
London who had a exposure to a bacteria
in India 20 years ago who had food
allergies That Couldn't overcome that
bacteria and I watched this woman
synchronistically
unbeknownst to the woman laying down
there lay a coherent energy in that
person's body and that woman was healed
I had dinner with her in London and she
was eating salmon and rice and
everything else and she said I don't
know what happened but I got healed now
that person who did the healing
her belief was challenged and because
she had the experience she asked the
greater question so the greater question
then led to the next experience but it's
not enough to do it once
you got to be able to repeat that
experience you got to make it scientific
right you got to get a beauty and make
it a skill and this is where people stop
like they have the one experience and
say I'm a Healer no
the fact that you have the experience
means you should be able to reproduce
that
so then you keep pushing the boundaries
of your beliefs that's called Evolution
and so people reach a certain point in
their belief systems and they stop and
so I think the problem with a lot of
people in the spiritual Community is
they confuse Insight with belief like oh
you know I had a I have an I have
anxiety so my reason I have anxiety
because I have a chemical imbalance in
my brain that's what my doctor told me
and I get panic attacks and I got a
panic attack on a plane and I'm afraid
of planes and crowded places and so now
that you know that you have a chemical
imbalance in your brain does it heal
your anxiety no so then they go to the
they go to the psychologist they go to
their friend their friends as well it's
not a hardware problem it's not circuits
and molecules and chemicals
software problem you know your father
was overbearing he was a perfectionist
and and it's a soft it's a program and
you know it's from your past and
the person now has the insight
that their father was overbearing does
it heal the anxiety but they will see
that as a belief like my father was
overbearing what they're really saying
is I am this way because of this past
experience so then they go to the
psychic and the psychic says you were
burned at the stake in Carcassonne in
the 1500s you're a Charismatic Christian
the memories burned in your soul now
that you know that you are a Charismatic
Christian from the 1500s a cathar a
Templar does it heal your anxiety no so
then you go to the astrologer and she
says you know Mercury is in retrograde
don't leave the house for six months
it's the reason why the way you are the
way you are and so they develop beliefs
that are within their emotional
acceptance
and so then they build more beliefs
within those emotions which means I
still don't want to change the Insight
doesn't change anything because people
will only accept believe and surrender
to beliefs or thoughts that are equal to
their emotional state and they'll
program their autonomic nervous system
into that Destiny so then you get a
diagnosis from a doctor it creates the
emotion of fear or desperation you'll
only accept belief and surrender to the
thoughts equal to those emotional states
until you change your emotional state is
it possible for you then to begin to
accept believe and surrender their
thoughts equal to a new emotional state
and bring up the emotion ahead of the
experience now we're talking about
going against conditioning rule number
three create your reality when you teach
people how to connect to the energy of a
future dream and be defined by a vision
of the future instead of the memories of
the past to believe in their future more
than they believe in their past
to fall in love with their future more
than they fall in love with their past
and be able to combine that clear
intention of that future
and begin to feel the emotions of that
future before it's made manifest they're
broadcasting a whole new signature into
the field now the beauty behind that is
is that the longer you're conscious of
that energy
the more you're drawing that future to
you
which also means then the moment you get
in your car and start getting angry and
getting frustrated because you're in
traffic
now you just disconnected from the
energy of your future and now you're
back to the energy of your past and
those survival emotions exert less
effects on the nature of reality so now
you feel like matter trying to change
matter you're you're separate and so you
force it you control it you try harder
you wish you pray you hope I mean hope
is a beggar we do everything compete to
try to manipulate and make it happen
because we have limited resources then
so then when a person is able to sustain
or maintain that modified state of mind
and being
then the fun starts to happen because
you start seeing those synchronicities
you start seeing those coincidences
those opportunities those unknowns those
things start falling out of nowhere
because you are connected to that field
of information and not only are you
connected to it but you're also
beginning to influence it so then more
and more people are creating now
and less of less people are experiencing
the state of being called being a victim
so then if you're a victim then you
would say I was angry because of traffic
well then I would say to you well you
mean your outer world was controlling
how you think and feel some circumstance
some person something in your outer
world is actually controlling your
feelings and thoughts that means you're
victim to those circumstances but when
you change the way you think and feel
and it starts to produce effects in your
outer world now you start to realize
you're the creator of your life and the
moment you start seeing feedback in your
life
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to do it again
and now you're going to believe now
you're more of the creator of your life
and less of the victim of your life rule
number four install new hardware so you
ask yourself at the end of your day I do
this every day how'd I do how'd I do
today bro how'd you do just do good
where'd you fall from grace what what
what was it that caused you to go
unconscious
for the rest of the day like what was
that moment now if you're a student of
Life you'll begin to contemplate well it
was that person that said that thing
then I reacted or this I got this email
or things didn't go my way and I started
feeling angry or frustrated or fearful
the next time that happens how could I
involve my experience now you may have
to search for some answers of the best
model to build or you may actually have
a long contemplation and start to go God
the next time that happens I think I'm
gonna do this or I'm gonna do that or
I'm going to plan my behaviors and the
act of closing your eyes and rehearsing
what you're going to do
begins to install the neurological
Hardware in your brain to looks like you
already did it now the brain is no
longer a record of the past now it's a
map to the Future and if you keep
installing that Hardware the hardware
will become a software program which
means you'll just start acting like a
happy person why there's no magic there
you install the circuitry so
that's more important
than the news right it's more important
than answering any email or any text
it's more important than talking about
your past or some dinner if you can
begin to just think about how you're
going to do it differently that's the
building process neurologically already
so now you have to get conscious in
order to do that and it takes some time
it means you got to shut your cell phone
off you gotta close your door you gotta
take a break from everything out there
and begin to practice and so by
experience then
you start noticing oh here it comes here
comes the frustration here comes the
fear and now we've given people the
tools to be able to self-regulate to
create brain and heart coherence and so
you see people say excuse me one minute
I just need a minute
it takes some breaths they get back in
they connect to the energy of their
future this is incidental compared to
where they're going so they don't fall
from grace they don't allow their energy
to drop and so yeah in the beginning it
takes a lot because it takes a lot of
energy and awareness to stay conscious
and not go unconscious but if you're
persistent and you're determined then
you're sincere you begin to figure it
out you begin to say I am not going to
give my power away to that person or
that circumstance when I can use it to
heal or to create a new future and so
people then won't excuse themselves and
say on a hard day yesterday at a fight
with my co-worker or my ex or and I
don't feel like doing the work well
that's the time they get back on the
horse yeah because because it's the it's
all of those times that we self-correct
those are the most valuable moments thus
people who have had
profoundly transcendental experiences
where they we say got lit up they
connected and their brain goes into very
very high coherent States and super
gamma patterns that are way outside of
normal and they have a transcendental
downloader connection that's mystical
they look back at their entire life
they don't want to change one thing in
their past because it got them to that
moment that's the moment the past no
longer exists now by the same means they
look back at their past and they see all
those tough moments where they overcame
themselves and they fall in love with
that person they don't look at the good
meditations or the things that went well
they look they know that it was those
moments that got them to this moment and
I I think then that's when they begin to
understand that that all of the hard
work
all the effort in who we become makes no
one can take that away from us so then
once we arrive at that level and we
experience whatever the dream is or
whatever we create the next thing is do
it until you fully enjoy it and then
when it gets boring or predictable let's
go again let's do something else yeah
and I think that's Evolution also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five invest in your
future meditation the actual translation
of the word meditation means to become
familiar with so the first thing you
have to do is you have to become
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
you got to notice your automatic habits
and behaviors and you have to become
aware of your emotions that keep you
anchored to the past and if you can
become so conscious of the one
unconscious states of mind and body that
they would never slip by your conscious
awareness again you're becoming familiar
with the old self so you don't return
then if you begin to think about new
ways of being being defined by a vision
plan your behaviors review them in your
mind now if you keep doing that over and
over again nerve cells that fire
together wire together you begin to
become familiar with a new state of mind
at the same time if you can emotionally
cultivate your inspiration your joy Your
Enthusiasm ahead of the experience by
repeating that over and over again
cultivating that state it's going to
begin to become familiar to you so then
the process of change then requires
unlearning and relearning breaking the
habit of the old self Reinventing a new
self
pruning synaptic connections as we say
in neuroscience and sprouting new
connections unmerizing emotions that are
stored in the body then here's the key
reconditioning the body to a new mind
into a new emotion it's literally moving
from your past to your future it's
losing your mind and creating a new one
and so then when you begin to understand
that in the in that process it's going
to feel a little bit unfamiliar
uncomfortable and if you can relax into
that instead of going back to the past
continuously invest in your future
sooner or later it'll begin to become
easier and easier and easier and all of
a sudden when you least expect it
something amazing is going to happen in
your life and when that event begins to
occur you're going to pay attention to
what you did inside of you now to
produce the effect outside of you and
that's called human empowerment and
there isn't a person in the world that's
excluded from this equation rule number
six develop beliefs that serve you if
people are really really believing that
their astrological sign determines their
Destiny then they will look for based on
their perception the correlations that
are equal to their belief system I don't
particularly believe that because I'm
born at a certain time under certain
house that has anything to do with me
creating the life that I want to have
right so
many people will though and because they
do they'll only they'll select like oh I
saw 11 11 on the clock well
well you've seen three 236 on the clock
and 4 18 on the clock but you're looking
for 11 11. well then that's your reality
because that's where your attention is
right so I don't subscribe to that but I
respect that because that person is
going to keep that belief until it no
longer serves them and they're either
going to evolve their belief or they're
not and if they don't so be it but if
they do they're going to realize sooner
or later it's not working for them I
have certain beliefs right now
that I honestly am questioning that I
still think are limited beliefs but in
order for me to change those beliefs I'm
going to have to come out of my resting
state have to step out into the unknown
and really check to see and execute in a
very different way now
to build on that model
then it's going to require one foot
in the Practical World in one foot in
the Mysterious World because I can't
control all the events that happen in my
life but I can certainly make choices
that are going to bring me closer to
those experiences now I also know from
experience that when I'm living by the
hormones of stress and I'm living in
survival that you and I and everybody
else is always going to try to control
the outcome to try to force the outcome
to try to get in the way try to analyze
when it's going to happen and how it's
going to happen now when that occurs
we're really bad
we're competitive we're manipulative
we'll hold on to things we're deceitful
we're greedy because that's what those
chemicals do so we're always trying to
control and force the outcome because in
a sense we feel separate from something
greater we feel like we're matter trying
to change matter we feel like uh we're
we're vibrating at the same speed as
everything else and so we have to get
what we want means we have to go and get
it and and and so then people start
mixing spiritual principles with that
phenomenon right so then
that's not what I'm talking about
because I'm talking about
if you're able
to understand that when you're living by
the hormones of stress that your senses
are heightened
and that you're materialist trying to
Define reality if you can't see it feel
a taste it smell it doesn't exist and
you're getting ready for something bad
to happen and be prepared and protect
yourself and that's how most people live
then everybody's doing that everybody's
mad at trying to change matter and the
soonerly we're going to bump into each
other and there's going to be Sparks
right so then is it possible then
that instead of being defined as a body
living in an environment in a particular
time
that if you were to close your eyes and
disconnect from the external environment
to sit your body down
into transcend time
and to become nobody
you have the biological Machinery to do
this to become no one you're not a face
you're not a man you're not a
documentary filmmaker
you're not your past you're not your
future you're not a husband
you're not your body you're not your
emotions you're not your habits you're
not the predictable future of the
familiar past
your pure consciousness
now if you are going to heal your body
by thought alone
if you are going to create some event in
your external environment by thought
alone and if you are going to transcend
Time by thought alone then you have to
become thought alone
and so when people start to really
realize that they can change the
neurosircuitry in their brain by thought
alone send new emotional signals that
begin to select and up regulate new
genes and down regulate other genes and
it may take knocking on that door
for extended periods of time to finally
the gene is programmed because it took
them 10 years to program the gene for
the disease it may take them a few years
to reprogram the gene
now we're talking about pragmatist we're
talking about someone who's applying
some principles and so then when that
occurs
and the energy that was sitting in these
hormonal centers of survival of anger
and fear and guilt and shame the energy
kind of moves up a little bit we've
measured This Heart starts to open gets
more coherent the field around the body
begins to grow we've measured that the
person feels more like energy less like
matter they feel like more like wave
less like particles they're not afraid
of the unknown they let's go ahead and
answer that really quick he's in like
the greatest part right now
you said knocking on the door I was like
Yeah ironic
[Music]
oh thank you
all right hopefully you didn't lose your
train of thought so
they're not afraid of the unknown
they're craving them they're trusting in
the unknown
and that that kind of expanded energy
is now their no longer
enslaved emotionally to the Past
they're no longer an identity that's
connected to a disease they're no longer
a body who's addicted to an emotion
they're no longer trying to forecast the
future based on the past they're no
longer a man they're no longer a woman
they're no longer a nurse they're no
longer black they're no longer white
they're no longer anything
they're they're a they are completely
poised in the present moment and that
that that present moment produces a
liberation of energy because the body is
no longer
held to the chains of the past and that
liberation of energy then begins to
produce a biological transformation in
the brain and the body we've seen it the
brain gets highly coherent yet super
organized the person feels whole
we've measured that their heart moves
into a state of joy and and love and
gratitude we measured that the field
around their bodies enhanced we measure
that and the person could no longer
cares about the future of the past or
happy in the present moment they no
longer want anything because they're
whole
and if you're whole it's impossible to
want and that's the moment it happens
and so kind of this Paradox that begins
to occur so why am I explaining it like
this because I want to answer the
ultimate question of what you're asking
is that there's an intelligence that's
giving us life
it's keeping my heart beating and
digesting my food and food and
organizing trillions of functions per
second in every cell of my body I'm not
doing that I'm having a conversation
with you as a free-willed subject of
consciousness
but there is an intelligence within me
that's always endorsing who I'm being
and that intelligence is a Giver of Life
so to demystify it then and this is
where
i s i part from the spiritual community
because when your will
matches its will
when your mind matches its mind when
your love for Life matches its love for
life it begins to work in ways that are
mysterious now
why is that important because the
mysterious is the unknown and the
unknown is unexpected and the unexpected
should bring a surprise and that
surprise should be outside of my current
beliefs if it's happening how could I
expect the supernatural to happen if I'm
expecting it to happen
that it's impossible but if I'm in the
unknown and I'm open
to possibility then I should be able to
create an unknown experience that I
can't predict the emotion or the future
event of how it's going to occur when
it's going to occur it's not my job and
the side effect of that is this
mysterious surprise that changes my
biology from the new experience and then
causes me to change my beliefs and I've
I've had enough of my own mystical
moments in the midst of that mystical
experience I have said in the midst of
it I have this all wrong I have said it
right in the midst of the experience I
am doing this so wrong because I was so
programmed into this box of belief
but the only way the unexpected could
happen
is giving up expectation which means you
have to surrender that belief how it's
going to happen or when it's going to
happen I can't predict that so then that
same intelligence that's giving me life
according to the quantum model of
reality is the same intelligence that's
creating supernovas and causing flowers
to bloom it's it's within us and all
around us it's it's a very wave of
quantum physics I can't control that I
can't expect how the particle is going
to appear or when it's going to appear
but it's not my job
my job is to move into different states
of being and be open to the mystery of
how it's going to happen so
if I said to you today Ben that I had
all the answers
to everything I would I would certainly
be limiting this conversation but I am
open to the to the mystery of life and
the Mystery of Life then means that if
we're asking certain questions and we
believe we we even speculate that it's
possible and someone has to step out
into out of their present beliefs to see
if it is
and so I'm not interested in the natural
I'm not interested in the normal
I'm interested in the Supernatural the
super normal and I believe from my
present state of ignorance of course if
we're going to use the word belief
that you don't have to be a Buddhist
monk
you don't have to be a nun with 40 Years
of devotion you don't have to be a
religious scholar you don't have to be a
researcher you don't have to have a PhD
to do this
that common people around the world can
do the uncommon and if they're given the
right understanding
and the environment is set up where they
can begin the application of that
and I have looked at over a thousand
brain scans of people in meditation
and I can tell you that you and I are at
our absolute best when we get beyond our
analytical mind when we get Beyond
ourselves that's the moment
that the brain gets so organized and so
coherent the front of the brain is
talking to the back of the brain the
right side of the brain start on the
left side of the brain there's this
synchronization this psychic Union going
on a flow
and the person has tears of joy rolling
down their face that Gestalt moment
that that
Transcendent event for the person is
completely subjective but my interest is
measuring that subjective experience and
we're capturing amplitudes of energy in
people's brains that are 26 000 to 40
000 times normal during that experience
now
they can't make their brain do that it's
happening to them
and the inner event that's happening to
them is more real than any past event
and that's the moment I know their
belief is changing rule number seven go
all in can you teach your body
emotionally
what the future reality that you want to
live in feels like before it happens now
this is very difficult if you've been
conditioned into believing something in
your outer world has to change to make a
way take away the emptiness or the lack
to make you feel differently this is
saying actually feel the emotion before
it happens and don't wait for the
experience to occur teach your body what
the feeling will be before it occurs if
the environment signals the Gene and the
end product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion you're
signaling the gene ahead of the
environment and genes make proteins and
proteins are responsible for the
structure and function of your body and
the expression of proteins is the
expression of life so teach the body
emotionally to self-regulate to believe
it's living in an environment that's
flourishing that's wonderful keep
practicing it and it'll become familiar
to you and the process then
creates a new identity and it's not
difficult once you understand what
you're doing and why you're doing it and
the more you combine all those different
branches of science and make it in a
simple way to understand if people
understand the what and the why the how
gets easier because you can assign
meaning to what you're doing and it
becomes instrumental so get a group of
people a thousand people 1500 people 2
000 people into a room
teach them that information whether
they're coming for wealth or health a
relationship a new career a mystical
experience get them all together
and teach them and measure what can take
place in one week period of time and I
assure you that's more than 75 percent
of the people that go through and go all
in and Retreat from their lives and
remove the same stimulation from their
environment and not be in the same
conditions and teach them that
information and give them numerous
opportunities to apply it and numerous
opportunities to get Beyond themselves
all you need is that first person that
stands on the stage and says hey I
walked in here with Parkinson's disease
I have no idea what happened but I'm not
trembling anymore and boy that last
thing just something clicked for me and
the person in the audience is watching
the four minute mile right in front of
them and going wow that guy looks like
he's not a vegan he doesn't look like
he's particularly in shape but his
Parkinson's went away and wow I mean if
he could do it I could do it and
somebody else changes their belief and
now that's a footprint and Consciousness
get enough people doing that
by the end of the week you're going to
see things we've seen blind people
seeing deaf people hearing that once not
twice people with Strokes for 10 years
lift their arms up again we've seen
people step out of wheelchairs people on
crutches drop their cracks I mean you
see
the body literally recalibrates to a new
mind and and they're not intentionally
trying to do anything they're just
becoming somebody else but the process
of overcoming
is the process of becoming and if you
teach people that formula and you get
just one or two people doing it it's
just going to become an infection and
it's gonna Wellness is gonna spread just
like disease rule number eight have a
vision I think it's a time in history
where it's not enough to know it's a
time in history to know how
and if you think about it um
most people live their life in a habit
they think the same thoughts they
perform the same actions they live by
the same emotions but they secretly
expect their life to change
but how you think how you act and how
you feel is called your personality and
your personality creates your personal
reality that's it so if you think sixty
to seventy thousand thoughts in one day
and ninety percent of those thoughts are
the same thoughts as the day before the
same thoughts always lead to the same
choices the same choices always lead to
the same behaviors the same behaviors
create the same experiences and the same
experiences produce the same emotions
and those same emotions then drive your
very same thoughts and so you get caught
in this kind of biological neurological
and Quantum fixated pattern
so then the hardest part about change
really in creating the life that you
want being defined by a vision of the
future instead of a memory of the past
is not making the same choices you did
the day before and the moment you do
that you step into the unknown now you
and I have been conditioned and
hypnotized into believing that the
unknown is some scary place but when you
begin to realize the unknown is the
perfect place to create from that void
of unpredictability and uncertainty that
unfamiliarity is really the quantum
place of uncertainty where all
manifestations come from so when you and
I become comfortable living in that
unknown place I think then that we begin
to manifest the things we want in our
lives so for me personally
I want to execute and be defined by a
vision of the future instead of the
memories of the past so most people's
brains are organized to reflect
everything they know in their life their
brain is a record of the past
and if you feel the same way every
single day and feelings and emotions are
the end product of past experiences it
means number one nothing new is
happening in your life and number two
those emotions are keeping you anchored
to the past if thoughts are the language
of the brain and feelings are the
language of the body and how you think
and how you feel creates a state of
being most people are literally
biologically neurologically chemically
genetically and even Quantum wise
connected to a past
so then the question is the fundamental
question is
can you believe in a future that you
can't see or experience with your senses
yet but you've thought about enough
times in your mind that your brain has
literally changed to look like the
experience has already occurred now the
latest research in neuroscience and
neuroplasticity tells us we can change
our brain to look like the event has
already occurred and can we begin to
emotionally Embrace a future reality
that's a potential in the quantum field
and begin to emotionally embrace it to
such agree that we fall in love with
that future reality that our bodies Our
unconscious mind begins to believe it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and we're signaling new
genes in new ways to change our body to
look like the experience has already
occurred in preparation for the event
now think about this so making our inner
World more real than the outer world
right but not only that
you have to then understand that when
you truly do this properly you're not
waiting for your healing to feel whole
you're not waiting for your success to
feel empowered you're not waiting for
your wealth to feel abundant you're not
waiting for your new relationship to
feel love you're not waiting for the
mystical moment to feel awe that's the
old model of reality of cause and effect
waiting for something outside of you to
change how you feel inside of you and
when you feel better inside and you pay
attention to whoever whatever caused
that that's that's cause and effect and
when you begin to make the correlation
between what changed you from outside
and inside you create an associate of
memory
the quantum model of reality begins to
say then you have to teach your body
emotionally how that future is going to
feel like before it's made manifest in
other words you have to feel awe in
order for the mystical moment to happen
you have to feel a abundance before your
wealth can occur you have to feel in
love with life before your new
relationship happens and so we're not
defining Reality by our senses because
we're not waiting then for anything
outside of us to change how we feel
inside of us so if there's physical
evidence in your brain and body to look
like the experience has already occurred
physical evidence
because the epigenetic model of reality
says you can change your body by thought
alone you and neuroplasticity says you
can change your brain by thought alone
so if there's physical evidence to look
like the experience has already occurred
well relax because the experience is
going to find you and it's going to come
in a way that you least expect rule
number nine eliminate addictions the
survival emotions the emotions that are
derived from the hormones of stress are
very addictive anger is addictive fear
is addictive sadness is addictive
resentment is addictive competition is
addictive frustration is addictive all
of those emotions that are derived from
the hormones of stress give the brain
and body A Rush of energy so if an
addiction is something you can't stop
and you happen to have a friend or a
family member who's walking around
suffering every single day of their life
and you say to them why don't you stop
or you you're in the middle of an angry
experience and I say to you Michael why
don't you just stop being angry if you
can stop
you can't stop that that on some level
you're addicted because an addiction is
something you can't stop so when people
start to understand oh my God I'm
addicted to my own frustration I'm
addicted to my own suffering I'm
addicted to my own guilt all of a sudden
they start becoming conscious of what
they're doing to their brain and body
show them how those very chemicals down
regulate genes to create disease
and then get them beyond that by doing
meditation that's the moment then all of
a sudden they begin to be greater than
their biology and we've measured this
thousands of times in people and it's
without a doubt I can say this from
every single cell in my being that a
person is at their absolute best when
they get Beyond themselves that's the
bottom line seventy percent of the time
people live in by the hormones are
stress whether they know it or not
they're always anticipating the future
based on the past they're always having
their attention on objects and people
and things and places in the world
because that's where the danger is the
chemicals are jacking up their body so
their attention is on their body so they
think based on their own experience that
they're their body but they're not they
believe that they're their identity
that's connected to relationships of
people and things and places in their
life but they're not then when people
start to live on autopilot and they get
out of bed the same way and they brush
their teeth of the same hand and they do
all the same things every single day and
they've been doing that for 20 or 30
years for the most most part then their
bodies on autopilot it's in a
predictable future based on what it's
done in the past so very few people are
in the present moment so then they're
locked into a line of time a linear line
of time where their future and their
past seem to be exactly the same so no
not a lot of people are present or in
the present moment and if you're not in
the present moment I assert that you're
running some type of program which means
you're not present the body's already
programmed to be in the future in the
past so then
in an elegant moment of meditation and
we've we can predict this now on a brain
scan there comes a moment where a person
forgets about their body
they forget they're they're so involved
in their inner world that there is
nobody
they forget that they are an identity
they're not paying attention to the
people they know and the places they go
and the things they have to do or the
things they own they become no one they
become no thing they go to nowhere and
they forget about their appointments and
their past and they become no time and
that is the moment they become pure
Consciousness that is the moment that
they begin to disconnect from their
biology and who you are to answer that
question is a Consciousness that's
manipulating the brain and body to
produce different levels of mind
and only when you are pure consciousness
can you begin to change your body only
when you are beyond your body can you
heal your body you can't the body can't
heal the body you have to get beyond
your body to heal your body in order for
you to create some new experience in
your life you got to get beyond the
problems in your life in order for you
to create some new future event in some
future time you got to get Beyond
predictable linear time and so if you're
going to heal your body by thought alone
if you're going to create some
experience in your life by thought alone
if you are going to create some new
event in your future by thought alone
then you have to become thought alone
and that is the moment when you become
pure Consciousness where you are nobody
no one no thing nowhere in no time that
is the moment
that you're no longer constrained by
those laws that is the moment your
Consciousness freewilled subjective
human consciousness merges with the
quantum field the objective Universal
Consciousness and when they come
together and you come back to awareness
you take a piece of it with you and you
become more like it you become more
willful it has an amazing will you
become more mindful it has an infinite
mind become more conscious it has a
great Consciousness you become more
loving it's a it's a love it's a lover
of life you become more Giver giving
it's a giver of life it's it's nature
becomes your nature and so teaching
people how to do that uh is the art so
then when you understand that you we we
we now know that there's certain ways to
do that that help people get there
faster and Rule Number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
live a stress-free life according to the
psychological and scientific model
the majority of people in their waking
day in a normal day spend about 70
percent of their time living in stress
and living in stress is living in
survival
and the actual definition of stress
stress is when your body's knocked out
of homeostasis
stress is when your body's not that of
balance
the stress response is what your body
innately does to return itself back to
order you have three types of stress you
have physical stress like trauma
injuries accidents Falls you have
chemical stress like bacteria viruses
blood sugar levels heavy metals and
Foods hangovers whatever
and you have emotional stress like
traffic jams internet connections second
mortgages single parenting 401ks family
tragedies all of those things knock the
brain and body out of balance
now all organisms in nature can adapt to
short-term stress
pack of coyotes chases a deer in the in
the forest the deer outruns the coyotes
the stress is over the theory turns back
to homeostasis and it grazes again the
event is over when the deer perceives a
threat in its external environment it
turns on a primitive nervous system
called the fight-or-flight nervous
system
and that autonomic nervous system that
sympathetic nervous system begins to
mobilize enormous amounts of energy for
some threat in the external environment
now
the year has all its physiology changed
all the blood is sent to the extremities
heart rate increases respiratory rate
rate increases pupils dilate dilate the
1300 chemicals that are created in a
matter of seconds is to cause the deer
to survive in some difficult condition
now
human beings have the same mechanisms
and when we perceive a threat in our
external environment like a lion we are
going to run or fight or freeze
but if you've had problems with your
co-worker
or you've had a very difficult
experience with your mother-in-law
the moment you perceive your
mother-in-law or your co-worker you and
you have a past experience with them
you're going to turn on the same
primitive nervous system
just like you were being chased by a
lion so what was once highly adaptive
now becomes very maladaptive because
when you're mobilizing all of that
energy
you are going to operate in very
predictable ways you're going to be an
amped up animal with a big memory bank
so that your blood flow is going to go
to the hind brain and away from the
forebrain which means you're going to
react instead of think
rationalize
but human beings the privilege of being
a human being is that we can make
thought more real than anything else
that's the privilege
so then you can begin to forecast
some future worst case scenario
and you can attend to that thought to
the exclusion of everything else
and you can focus on it to such a degree
that you will begin to anticipate the
event and produce the same chemicals as
if you're in that experience and you're
knocking your brain and body out of
balance just by thought alone
you can begin to unfold some past bitter
memory that's tattooed in the recesses
of your gray matter and like magic you
can bring it to life and in that moment
it's real and you will produce the same
chemistry in your brain and body as if
that event occurred and your body is the
unconscious mind is literally living
that experience
so then when we're living by the
hormones of stress and you turn on that
stress response and you can't turn it
off now you're headed for some disease
because no organism in nature can
tolerate living in emergency mode for
extended periods of time so if 70 of the
time a person's living in survival
living in stress in survival what we do
in order to survive
as we are going to select the worst case
scenario
and we are going to begin to plan our
behaviors and our emotions in that
experience because anything less than
the worst case scenario means we have
better chances of survival so we plan
for the worst we emotionally embrace it
and anything less means we can survive
so out of the infinite Potentials in the
quantum field
anxiety really represents a poor
imagination but it's highly adaptive if
it's if you're living in survival
because you got to get ready for that so
seventy percent of the time people are
selecting the worst case event in their
life and emotionally embracing it and
they're they're programming their
autonomic nervous system into a very
specific Destiny and turns out if you
keep doing that and you create the
emotions of fear and worry and anxiety
and you do that for 10 years or five
years or three years your body is going
to unconsciously become programmed to
fear and it's going to have a panic
attack without you try as you may with
your conscious mind to control it you've
programmed it subconsciously and now the
body as the mind is running the show
so
the hormones of stress
create the emotions of anger
of aggression of hostility of violence
of frustration of hatred of fear of
anxiety of guilt of Shame of
hopelessness of powerlessness depression
those are all chemicals that are derived
from the hormones of stress and when we
live by the hormones of stress we become
very selfish why because when you're in
survival you've got to take care of the
self your tension is on your body right
your attention is on your external
environment there's Predators out there
the the rush of adrenaline causes the
senses to become heightened and you're a
materialist and you're trying to predict
the future because there's better
chances of survival if you can predict
the future based on the past when that
occurs then over time
the body begins to break down because
it's a scientific fact
that the hormones of stress down
regulate genes to create disease in the
long term
so if you can turn on the stress
response just by thought alone
and the hormones of stress can make you
sick
then your thoughts can literally make
you sick so the question is if your
thoughts can make you sick
is it possible then that your thoughts
can make you well
our immune system is kind of like our
rudimentary nervous system it has cells
that are mobile and they're called
plasma cells or white blood cells and
what their job is an internal defense in
many of our bodies plasma cells line the
mucous membranes got the digestive tract
all the orifices of the body the nose
the mouth ears
and it's a line of defense against
foreign Invaders and toxins and when the
immune system is facing some foreign
Invader whether it be a virus a bacteria
a mold a fungus some foreign agent
it is the army of plasma cells that move
towards the danger and begin to attack
these foreign agents and
there are cells in your immune system
called t cells and T cells are like the
ninjas of the immune system they release
very powerful chemicals that can
denature and break down any foreign
Invader and T cells have these little
trumpets that stick out on the receptor
site so picture this big circular
spherical glob and you have all these
different receptors and these T cell
receptors are these long trumpet
appendages
and when they come up to a virus or they
come up to a bacteria when they come up
to even a cancer cell
they notice that is a foreign agent and
immediately this T Cell receptor
attaches to that foreign agent and
begins to release a lot of unhealthy
chemicals that begin to cause that
foreign agent to to die and then
memorizes that foreign agent and passes
the information onto the army of the
rest of the white blood cells in the
body and and this is a strong immune
system and when plasma cells and white
blood cells
uh begin to function well they release
chemicals called immunoglobulins
and immunoglobulins are proteins that
are in the shape of a y and those
y-shaped proteins are antibodies and
what they do is when the the white blood
cell releases an antibody it begins to
block The receptors of the foreign agent
that's trying to attack the white blood
cells so when a healthy immunoglobulin
is released it suppresses the the
Warfare the the cell receptors that are
trying to attack the white blood cell
and now you have a strong defense you
have a strong immune system and at your
body right now is doing that in fact
your body is always evaluating all those
foreign agents whether it's a virus a
bacteria or even a cancer cell
and it's working to keep the body in
balance and the immune system a strong
healthy immune system does that
constantly always behind the scenes of
your awareness if you give people sound
information
and then they can repeat that
information
they're wiring it in their brain
they're creating a new model of
understanding
if you show them how to apply that
information
if they do it properly they will have
some type of transformation
that transformation isn't something that
causes people to feel bad or unworthy it
causes them to open their hearts
it causes them to feel Joy to feel
gratitude they feel differently
and if you're able to then create that
elevated emotion and you teach people
more information they will continue to
transform themselves and that's called
Evolution if you think the same thoughts
the same thoughts always lead to the
same choices the same choices lead to
the same behaviors the same behaviors
create the same experiences and the same
experiences produce the same feelings
and you're now caught in your old self
but new thoughts should lead to new
choices and new choices should lead to
new Behaviors new behaviors should
create new experiences and new
experiences should create new emotions
and that should Inspire evolution
we say that your personality creates
your personal reality
and your personality is made up of how
you think how you act and how you feel
we could say that your personality is
your state of being
so now geniuses
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
keep demonstrating the same behaviors
keep living by the same feelings and
emotions your personal reality is going
to stay exactly the same
but if you have new thoughts
that lead to new choices that
demonstrate new actions that create new
experiences that cause you to feel
differently you will begin to walk into
a new future how many people understand
this
so most people try to create a new
personal reality as the same personality
and it doesn't work you literally have
to become someone else
so crossing the river of change going
from the old self to the new self
requires you stepping into the unknown
and if you are now in the unknown and
you feel uncomfortable because you're
leaving guilt behind
[Music]
you leave unworthiness behind you see
the biggest problem with most people
is they want to create wealth but they
feel lack
they want a new life but they feel
unworthy
that's mind and body and opposition
and our research shows that you can
teach people how to recondition their
body to a new mind
and when that occurs they begin to
create very powerful things in their
life we have such compelling evidence in
science with brain scans you make your
brain work better you can make your
heart work better you can make your
immune system work better you can make
your cells go from really sick to really
healthy we've got great evidence you can
become immune to Serious viruses you can
be immune in the bacteria we've got the
measurements you can lengthen your life
we have great evidence and people aren't
monks they're not they're not nuns
they're not religious Scholars they're
just common people and then we have
testimony
people who are the example of Truth they
are they are the example of truth I
would rather have dinner with those
people than anybody anybody else they
know something right
so evidence then becomes the loudest
voice right and and that's what I think
what people are looking for right now
the truth is so lost in sensationalism
and the truth is so lost in emotional
agreement and so people who want to feel
fear
they program themselves and accept
believe and surrender that people who
want to be hate be hateful
it's all there it's all there and it's a
it's a matrix to find the way out right
and and I think I think there's a door I
just I just think that we have to trust
the innate information that that comes
from within us can you believe in a
future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet
but you've thought about enough times in
your mind that your brain is literally
changed to look like the event has
already occurred
latest research in neuroscience
says you can change your brain from
living in the past to living in the
future
and can you fall in love with that
vision
to such a degree
that you come out of your resting state
and change guilt or suffering into
inspiration and joy and gratitude
to such a degree that your body as the
unconscious mind does not know the
difference between that external event
and what you're creating internally
so that your body believes it's living
in that future in the present moment and
you begin to Signal new genes in new
ways to change your body to look like
the event has already occurred
the latest research in epigenetics says
you can change your body by thought
alone
now reason this with me
if there's physical evidence in your
brain and body to look like the event
has already occurred
your brain and body are no longer living
in the past they're living in the future
and you will walk right into your vision
most people in this audience
all of you
have done something great in your life
you all have
a reason this
you woke up one day or you had a wild
thought out of nowhere
and that thought was a possibility in
the future
something new you wanted to experience
and you started thinking about this
experience the moment you started
contemplating
this potential reality
you turned on a part of your brain
called the frontal lobe
the crowning achievement of the human
being
it's 40 percent of your entire brain it
is the creative Center
and it has connections to all other
parts of the brain
and the moment you said what would it be
like to be a leader
what would it be like to be successful
what would it be like to have this
Vision come true
the moment you asked that open-ended
question you turned on this part of the
brain
because the rest of the brain is just a
bunch of automatic programs
and now the frontal lobe the creative
Center wakes up
and it has connections to the entire
brain it's the CEO it's the boss it's
the symphony leader of the brain
and the moment you get creative the
frontal lobe begins to select different
networks of neurons that are stored in
your brain from things you've learned or
experienced
and as you begin to think a what-if
question it begins to select these
different networks and begins to
seamlessly piece them together and
making your brain fire in new sequences
and in new patterns and new combinations
and whenever you make your brain work
differently you're changing your mind
because mind is the brain in action mind
is the brain at work
and the moment those neurons fire in
tandem
you get a picture in your mind
a hologram
a vision an abstraction
and for those people who are passionate
that thought that they're thinking
begins to create an elevated emotion
they become inspired
they feel enthusiastic in Theos filled
with God
they become passionate they started to
open their hearts
and all of a sudden they're combining a
clear intention with an elevated emotion
and it's the combination of a clear
intention and an elevated emotion in our
research over and over again that proves
then the person now is changing
fundamentally changing biologically
changing internally
and their brain and body are moving from
living in the past into living in the
future people that were traumatized from
childhood that were abused sexually
physically emotionally that were
suicidal that had all kinds of health
conditions they came to the edge
of that emotion that kept them connected
to the past and they were ready to give
up in one meditation because
they they never had felt an emotion like
this that they could remember that it
was so intense
they thought about all the times for the
last year that they never missed a day
of doing a meditation even when they
didn't feel like it or when they wanted
to quit halfway through and they didn't
they went all the way they thought about
all those times that they went to that
point and they went one more time really
and their words are always the same and
my heart blew wide open and I looked
back at my entire past and I don't want
to change one thing in my past because
it brought me to this present moment and
I can see my betrayers I could see the
people in my life uh that had a hand in
this and I have nothing but compassion
for them because now the person is no
longer viewing that past from the same
level of Consciousness they're viewing
it from a place of Love of wholeness and
they see the greater good of all of it
and now they're they're they're
conditions their health conditions their
endometriosis their uterine tumors I
mean whatever it is literally
goes disappears and they have an
incredible incredible change in their
brain chemistry they're in love with
life they're off their meds they're not
suicidal they're why would they be
they're free
so it can happen in an instant when the
heart is healed and everybody gets the
new signal the body's out of the past
the body's no longer feeling the
emotions of the past and sometimes
we got to come right up against that
edge that's yeah that's the great moment
when a person begins to slow their brain
waves down they have to go when you're
in stress when you're in survival you
narrow your focus on a cause that's
called a what's called a convergent
Focus so now you're blessing the energy
centers of the body they're under the
control of the autonomic nervous system
and when the autonomic nervous system
moves out of balance the brain moves out
of balance right we now are focus on the
cause and it causes each one of these
different energy centers
to move into incoherence as well and
those little little individual brains
start moving into incoherence and send
an incoherent message to the cells and
tissues and organs hormones then become
down regulated and the body starts
moving out of balance
so when we bless the energy centers
where we reprogram these energy centers
two things has to happen
they have to be able to slow their brain
waves down they have to get out of that
high beta State and the way we do it is
to go from a narrow Focus to a broad
focus when you open your focus when you
open your awareness that's what creates
coherence in the brain because you're
going against that habit
putting your attention on matter
so there's a convergent Focus which is
focusing on matter and then there's a
Divergent Focus which is focusing on
energy well reality is both particle and
wave matter and energy so if a person
can slow their brain waves down from
beta brain waves to Alpha brain waves
now they're starting to fall out of
their thinking brain right into the home
of the autonomic nervous system okay the
person can't change their brain waves
it'll never work because they're in
their neocortex in their thinking mind
right so that's one thing that has to
happen the second thing that has to
happen is that they have to practice
both a convergent focus and a Divergent
Focus now by the convergent you're
focusing on let's say I'm going to focus
on this energy center right and then you
move your focus to another energy well
first you first you focus on that energy
center that's particle and then you
focus on the space around it that's wave
and so when you open your awareness and
you're able to do that and you're in
your autonomic nervous system you can
put an intention there which will create
more balance and estrogen more balance
and your your sexual organs you move to
your second Center you put your
attention there that's your where you
place your attention is where you place
your energy so now you're beginning to
Direct Energy yeah into that Center but
now you become aware of the space around
it why to create coherence and that
little brain send the coherent message
to the cells and tissues go to your
third center right in the pit of your
gut well there's a huge Celiac plexus
there a solar plexus a lot of
connections in there so now put your big
one that's a big always getting a lot of
signs there yeah here and here part and
solar plexus yeah that's those are big
ones and you tune into that energy then
you put your attention in your heart it
has its own individual brain yeah and
when you make energy here when energy
finally arrives here guess where it goes
automatically straight up we've measured
it so now once you start opening your
heart you've got more energy in your
heart you get more energy in your brain
got it show it on time just go straight
to the heart that's why we do it that's
exactly why we that's why we open the
heart so it creates a field and it
begins to drive energy of the brain so
now that energy is going to cause the
person
to have a different Consciousness a
different thought pattern right and now
they're going to be thinking possibility
because in survival the first three ones
are all about survival yeah it's really
not a creative process of creating from
mind it's more about a more primitive
you know
um
humanistic part of us you know animal
part of us so then there's the thyroid
plexus the pineal gland the pituitary
gland so we've seen when people create
coherence in each one of these energy
centers and they do it properly they
know how to change their brain waves
they get into the operating system they
can Master convergent and Divergent
Focus they're no longer living just this
way they've practiced opening their
awareness and focus on energy becoming
conscious of it and as these brains
become more coherent and they start
producing different signals to hormones
and chemicals and into different glands
in the body that's what's being
upregulated to make different different
Expressions I want to show you what it
looks like
when you learn something new you have a
hundred billion neurons in your brain
a hundred billion neurons
the number of connections you have in
one neuron is between ten thousand and
forty thousand connections if you took
and you stack
Five Thousand Miles High that's the
distance from Los Angeles to London
if you took a scoop of gray matter the
size of a grain of sand you would have a
hundred thousand neurons in it with over
a billion connections now
I'll stop right after this slide
learning is making new synaptic
connections every time you learn
something new this is what's happening
in your brain geniuses
if you learned one bit of information
today
your brain did this
boom that's learning
physical evidence as a result of your
interaction in the environment
every time you learn something in your
brain there's a physical change that
takes place and learning is making new
connections
are you with me
this is how fast it happens too
that's learning if you learn anything
this week you've made a footprint if
learning is making new synaptic
connections
then if you keep firing the same
thoughts over and over again you're
going to wire them in your brain
so then if learning is making new
synaptic connections then remembering is
maintaining them
and all of a sudden they develop a
long-term relationship and just like any
relationship the more you communicate
the more they connect and neurons are
exactly the same way
now as you begin to learn information
neurons tend to assemble themselves into
networks or what's called neural
networks and neural networks are just
gangs of neurons that have fired and
wired together to form a community of
neurosynaptic connections that's related
to a thought a skill a habit a behavior
a concept
and neural networks are automatic
programs you have a neural network to
brush your teeth to put on makeup to
speak a language to walk
all of a sudden those neurons then form
a hardware circuitry but if you keep
repeating it the hardware becomes a
software program and it becomes
automatic people think that they want
certain things because they're
experiencing lack
and and so they have to go about
becoming
the very person so then if we reframe it
and you say oh I really want to be
wealthy I want all my needs met and I'll
say really why you want to be wealthy
and they'll say because I want freedom
I'd say okay let's focus on freedom
so now the person understands the
sponsoring thought or the emotion why
would you wait for your wealth to feel
free that's the Newtonian model of
reality of cause and effect waiting for
someone or something out there to take
away this emptiness or lack and what if
I'm feeling this emotion this emotion is
influencing certain thoughts and how I
think and feel creates my life if I'm
living in lack I'm not going to create
anything new
but if I say to you hey when you become
that person
once you become it then your your
reality is going to reorganize itself
instead of living by cause and effect
let's teach you how to cause an effect
so then the person then is no longer
interested in getting something in their
environment when they realize it's about
who they become
and all of a sudden now the emphasis or
the interest is in becoming that person
and we have a week with those people and
I want them to walk as it sit as it
stand as lay down and I said I want them
to get in the habit of walking from
their room to the ballroom it's become
the new habit that's why when we do our
work you're we're doing sitting
meditations we're doing standing and
walking meditations we're doing lying
down meditations I want it to become a
new habit I want them to become that
person we're all faced with uh
great challenges brilliantly disguised
as impossible situations and there's
always a door there is always a door
and so
your personality creates your personal
reality it's that simple and your
personality is made up of how you think
how you act and how you feel so the
present personality who's listening to
this show has created the present
personal reality called their life which
means if you're going to change
something in your personal reality
in your life you got to change your
personality you have to change nothing
changes
until you change that's the bottom line
you change but you the thought of
changing my personality seems so like
but I like who I am kind of but I'm also
cranky I'm also annoyed so like who is
that person underneath
all of these ailments I guess all of
these but it's a weird thing to say you
change your personality
well look I mean there's many things
that I love about my personality just
like you do I'm gonna take that with me
but there are things if I'm going to be
defined by a vision of the future
they're things that can't come because
the moment you say I want to have a
mystical experience where I transcend
this three-dimensional world and and you
want to have a really profound moment a
transcendental moment you start showing
up for that and it doesn't happen right
away then what you start disbelieving
you start Stop Believing yourself so so
the moment we're defined by a vision of
the future that's bigger than us that
vision of the future is not the vision
of the past and when we do that we take
away we take with us our discipline we
take our concentration we take our
presence we take our passion we take our
strengths with us all those things you
take but the things that are standing in
the way are those old beliefs are things
that stand in a way that that that that
stop you from connecting to it those are
the things you come up against and and
it's not the it's not the mystical
experience of the transcendental
experience it's who you become it's not
your wealth it's not your health it's
who you become it's not your freedom
it's who you become in the process and
it's the overcoming process that we
overcome that we overcome that we
overcome that we overcome till we
finally become and so many great people
in history you know even wealthy people
people always want to be wealthy but if
you study wealthy people that really did
it they failed miserably thousands of
times until they figured it out and so
you keep showing up for yourself enough
times
you're going to change you're going to
change you're going to be thinking
differently you're going to be acting
differently you're going to be feeling
differently and that's when the universe
starts to conspire in ways that we just
never even thought about that's that's
that's the beauty behind creation would
you say it's smart to focus on one goal
I mean if you're sick obviously it's
it's smart to focus on only getting
healthy but if you have a regular life
and you say you know I would like to
have the classical stuff for more money
uh more wealth more love more joy would
you say in those meditations it's smart
to focus on different goals or should it
rather be the Big Goal like a big Vision
I have for my life that all the steps on
the way are just
marks I will pass at one point well
let's answer that on two levels too
because people come to our workshops for
all different reasons some people come
because they're sick some people come
because they want more money some people
want more a new job a new opportunity a
new career a new relationship some
people want the mystical the people come
for all kinds of reasons to me I don't
care
what I care about is that they latch on
to a vision
and they learn how to create whatever
drives them to that elegant moment where
they're so present and so passionate
about what they want and they have a
clear intention a Clear Vision a
coherent brain
and they have an elevated emotion
combined with it that they create hard
coherence and now they're broadcasting a
whole new energy into the field and
whatever we broadcast into the field
is our experiment with Destiny
so I want people
to know the how because we have plenty
of people that have made millions and
millions of dollars that were living in
the back seat of their car or filed
bankruptcy we have plenty people that
were stage four cancers serious health
conditions that are healed but really
people think they come for those reasons
but we come for wholeness that's why we
come that when we feel so whole and so
happy with ourselves so connected to
something greater
if you feel wholeness
it's impossible for you to want
how can you want when you're whole when
you're whole you feel like you have
everything
so
I want people
to reach that point where
they feel so whole
uh that they no longer want and that's
when the magic happens teaching them
that
allows them to understand that when they
come back to their senses they open
their eyes
they're not looking
for the experience they feel like it's
already happened and if you feel like
it's already happened why would you be
looking for it then
if your body is conditioned emotionally
into that future
um you're not separate from the energy
of your future you're connected from it
to it but the moment you get in traffic
and you start getting angry you get on
the line at the bank and you start
getting impatient or you're sitting in a
staff meeting you start judging A
co-worker
you just disconnected from the energy of
the future and now you're back to the
energy of your past and you've done
nothing wrong
you just lost your connection to the
Future now now the importance of that is
to notice that you're disconnected and
if you say to me well that person made
me feel this way and think this way I'd
say oh my gosh you're back to the
unconscious program of being a victim in
your life the victim is saying that
someone or something is controlling how
I think and feel
a person who's producing outcomes in
their life all of a sudden they say wow
the way of thinking and feeling is
creating outcomes in my life
now I'm a creator of my life and now I
believe less and I'm a victim of my life
here's a deal with trauma and it's kind
of an interesting thing because when
you're traumatized some threat or some
danger or some condition in your outer
world through your senses is changing
how you feel in your inner world and the
quotient of change between the way you
normally feel in some alarm State when
you change your internal State and move
into that emergency mode you narrow your
focus on the cause and the Brain
freezes an image and takes a snapshot
and that's called the long-term memory
and now that image is branded
holographically into the brain so then
they remember experience our experience
is better because we can remember how
they feel and and that memory then
changes the person's biology so they
think neurologically within the circuits
of that experience and they feel
chemically within the boundaries of
those emotions and how we think and feel
becomes our state of being so so now the
person biologically is changed and many
times it's the strong emotion that
begins to select and instruct the gene
that creates disease why because if the
environment signals the Gene and that's
the truth that's epigenetics and the end
product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion the emotion
that you feel from that event is
literally selecting the gene gosh for
you to begin to change and the genes
make proteins and so the the person if
it's if it's strong enough begins to
wear their trauma not just in their
brain
now it's in their body because every
time they think about that trauma every
time they review it every time they keep
creating the imagery they keep firing
and wiring the circuits in their brain
and they keep feeling the feeling
emotionally in their body and their body
is so objective that it's believing it's
living in the same past experience 50 to
100 times a day and all you need is a
stimulus in response an image and an
emotion a thought and a feeling and
you're conditioning the body into the
past well you're conditioning the brain
body into the past the recognition that
when you're assimilating a negative
thought or a negative judgment or a
negative emotion and the greed whatever
it may be that's actually lowering your
energy yeah and when you get to that
place where you're experiencing that
incredible Bliss right here you can't
you can't yeah and even if you have the
thorn the thought will still come
because we still have those thoughts
that's the thought will be an
understanding of human nature because
you're no longer at that vibrational
level anymore or you're Rising above it
you know and and I think more and more
people are starting to figure that out
and and and the people in their lives
are like no my husband my husband is a
changed person no he's not the same guy
I know him I know he's completely
different and the guy's just like yeah I
feel amazing I feel great and all it was
was sitting in the fire yes for a little
bit of time until the body finally moved
out of the past into the present moment
and so
the causes of this like I always say you
never know
what you're doing today and how you're
doing it who you're going to affect
tomorrow when you do this work and
that's what we're seeing people are
they're they're they're they're getting
promotions uh they're getting all these
wonderful things not because of anything
that they're doing they're just
different yeah and people notice that
and they want those people in the
position to make better decisions for
the whole and I think that's uh that's
how we change the world you asked if is
it possible then can that people can
heal that quickly in one week yeah
because what if they create an inner
event
that carries an amplitude of gratitude
or Joy or Freedom breakthrough from the
chains of the past when the body is
liberated and you feel that elevated
emotion the stronger the emotion you
feel from that breakthrough the more
you're going to pay attention to the
image in your mind and now you're now
beginning to brand new circuitry in the
brain and your body's being conditioned
into a new future and the stronger the
emotion you feel and the more you pay
attention to the picture the more you're
conditioning the body over time to the
Future instead of the past so now
you keep knocking on that genetic door
emotionally then that emotion ultimately
signals a new Gene that up regulates
that genes produce better proteins and
the person and all of a sudden starts
healing and we have researched to show
that people can do that in four days
signal genes to reduce cancer cells wow
just to Signal stem cells to to suppress
um uh to go to active tissues and repair
them and regenerate them and suppress
inflammation you come with a lot of
genes and they're just a library of
potentials they're just a storehouse of
information of possibilities so then you
got to get the right signal the right
lock into the key that begins to select
and instruct genes that cause genes to
make different proteins and you can
regulate so many different genes the
same genes you can regulate them
differently so when they up regulate
they start producing really healthy and
robust proteins and that's that's
enzymes that's tissue that's structure
that's function that's harm
it's immune immunoglobulins when they
down regulate because of some alarm when
there's not a lot of energy
for long-term building projects well
then you keep doing that then the body
starts producing cheaper proteins it's a
different signal it's not a time for
growth why is our memory
for
pain stronger than our memory of a
success or a joy I really think that
when the survival Gene is activated
preservation is the key so we can have
10 things
it happened really great in our lives
you have a family member or somebody you
know that does this you have 10 really
great things happen in their one thing
bed and they focus on that bad thing why
because the survival genes activated
they want to make sure it doesn't happen
again so so you put your attention on it
because you don't want it to happen
again so what people do when they're
aroused is they start thinking it's
going to happen so they actually select
the worst
case scenario in their mind and then
emotionally Embrace that future before
it happens and they're conditioning
their body to become the mind of anxiety
and fear so in preservation and in
survival if you prepare for the worst
anything less that happens you have a
better chance of surviving so that's the
mechanism that takes place so
survival means you better take care of
your body yeah you better be aware of
your environment and make sure there's
no threats and so you got to keep your
eye out there
and you better be thinking about the
future based on what you learned in the
past now there's nothing wrong with that
when the analytical facilities are in
Balance but when there's an arousal
arousal there's three things that create
arousal fear
hostility and anger or aggression and
pain
and that arousal drives the brain
into these high states of what we call
High beta and most people need something
or someone or some circumstance or some
drug or some pill or some computer game
to change that internal State and the
moment they notice a change in their
Eternal faith and they pay attention to
what's causing it they start developing
a dependency on it right so
turns out that when we teach people how
to self-regulate and change their brain
waves we could actually see then that
the incoherence that disorderliness
that's taking place in the brain you
know when you're over aroused you're
overly analytical and you're shifting
your attention from one problem to one
person to one thing to one place to
another problem to another circumstance
to your phone to your car and each one
of those elements has a neurological
Network in the brain so the arousal
causes these different circuits to fire
out of order and the brain is incoherent
so take two waves that are out of phase
and mix them when they interfere they
flatten out there's no energy so energy
leaves the brain right
so then
when you're in arousal you narrow your
focus on the cause if there is something
rattling in the bushes and it's dark you
freeze and you narrow your focus on it
and there's a rush of adrenaline and
your pupils dilate and your heart starts
to race and you're ready to run fight or
hide I mean that's a survival moment but
what if it's your co-worker sitting
right next to you or six feet away and
and you're judging them you're the same
arousals taking place so what's once
very adaptive becomes very maladaptive
this is where it gets challenging so
when we teach people how to open their
focus we've done thousands and thousands
of brain scans and they get beyond their
analytical processes and they open their
awareness and go from a conversion Focus
to a divert and focus and they learn how
to relax and regulate their brain waves
start to slow down into Alpha and then
if they do it properly and they're
connecting
those different compartments of the
brain that were once firing out of order
start to unify different communities
form bigger communities the brain starts
to synchronize and then all of a sudden
you start seeing different compartments
of the brain all in resonance so now
when they're all in resonance and they
start interfering when those waves come
together there's more energy in the
brain so when a person dials down the
mechanism this neocortex that plugs us
into three-dimensional reality that
keeps us aware of our body that's the
autobiographical self where everything's
stitched in memory in there when we
start deactivating the mechanism here
and we get beyond the memory bank of the
known self and brain waves move into
Theta we we've studied this so much
when a person can let their body
be in a light state of sleep and feel so
safe
that you can finally let go and
surrender the body is sleeping but the
mind is awake and now the door between
the conscious mind and the subconscious
mind is wide open and if they can
regulate and stay there
something amazing happens
there is a release of energy
from the body and their brain goes into
a very very super coherent state of
gamma and Gamma is super Consciousness
now I'm not talking about
a little camera I'm not talking about a
lot of gamma I'm not talking about a
really loud camera I'm talking about a
supernatural amount of gamma
so there's so much order
and so much energy in the brain like if
we were in an audience and we were all
clapping like this
that could be Alpha right Theta would be
and if everybody could do this it's
slower we could do it the more we can
get our timing down the more we can get
coherent but if we were doing
this would be really hard for all of us
to do that at the same time it takes a
lot of order a lot of awareness a lot of
energy to be able to create that kind of
order so
that's how fast the brain is in that
arousal
that's taking place is ecstasy that
arousal is bliss it is the most familiar
unfamiliar feeling that people ever have
and that memory then that the person has
that is so profoundly different than the
feeling of success
the feeling of wealth the feeling of
orgasm or love or whatever this is a new
one and it's a thrill
and the person notices a dramatic change
in their inner State and with that
experience comes a very lucid picture a
very profound Insight a download of
information
that's the moment then the body many
times rewrites the biological program
energy
is informing matter and the autonomic
nervous system is regulating it's in
high order and remember diseases
autonomic dysregulation now it's getting
into a very very high frequency of order
and it's sending very coherent
information to the cells and tissues
sending energy to the cells and tissues
and cells begin to emit more coherent
light and information and then there's
the disease
and there it's not in our community at
least people who have relationships that
are built from our community tend to be
more long-lasting because they're more
self-aware and so there's no blame
there's no excuses there's no make wrong
there's no competition there's none of
that there's just this is who I am you
know and I think that the ultimate goal
is when you reach the point in your life
when how you appear to the world is who
you really are that level of
transparency is it takes no effort right
you can be yourself and and and you know
people say to me wow you're you're
pretty approachable and I say well God I
work so hard every day on overcoming
myself in the morning overcoming my ego
why would I want to build it up the next
day because I gotta face that guy again
tomorrow morning so why not just keep
you know you know taking those edges and
smoothing them down so that so that
you're you're less unconscious to all of
those programs that are built in
relationships the brain is a record of
the past it's an artifact of everything
we've learned and experienced to this
moment so most people wake up in the
morning and they think about their
problems and their problems or memories
that are etched in their brain that are
connected to certain people and certain
uh problems at certain times in certain
places and the moment they start
thinking of their problems they're
thinking in the past
the challenge is that every one of those
problems has an emotion associated with
it and emotions really are a record of
the past so the moment you feel unhappy
the moment you feel suffering the moment
you feel
fear now your body's in the past so it's
the thought being the language of the
brain and the feeling being the language
or the body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being so many
people reaffirm their state of being
completely uh by the past and so it only
takes a thought and a feeling an image
and emotion a stimulus in response to
start the conditioning process so we
start to condition the brain and body
hardwire the brain condition the body
emotionally into the past the problem is
the body's so objective that it doesn't
know the difference between the real
life experience that's creating the
emotion and the emotion we're creating
by memory alone the body's believing us
living in the same past environment 24
hours a day seven days a week 365 days a
year so
and the person gets up and then they run
through the same routine as they always
do and uh in time their body moves into
a state of autopilot now their body is a
set of programs a habit that's dragging
them into the same future based on what
they did in the past and so to change
them also requires being greater than
the emotions that have been conditioned
into the body and the habituations that
have been conditioned into the body in
the predictable future so we have to
understand then that change requires not
only being greater than the environment
but also being greater than our body
which is really for the most part been
conditioned to be the mind that's what a
habit is
so then
to change them to be greater than the
body to be greater than the environment
and be greater than time instead of
living in the familiar past which is the
known and the predictable future which
is the known you teach people how to
settle into the present moment and
that's the unknown and most people that
the unknown represents a very
threatening place and so when people
start to do meditation as an example and
their body starts looking for an arousal
or wants to get up and do things they
think they can't meditate but in fact if
they can settle their body back down
into the present moment and lower the
volume to that anger to that frustration
to the fear to the sadness
it's like training an animal now you're
telling the body it's no longer the mind
that you're the mind and our research
shows there's a liberation of energy the
body starts expanding and relaxing into
the present moment instead of getting up
and checking your cell phone or doing
something and you notice that propensity
instead of responding to it and saying I
can't meditate you settle your body back
down into the present moment now you're
executing a will
that's greater than the program because
most people lose their free will to a
set of programs and it's the act of
doing this to be greater than the
conditions of our environment be greater
than our body as the mind and and to be
greater than time
that all of a sudden causes the person
to start believing in themselves a
little bit more and that's when um
possibility starts to unfold if you have
a very brain driven person like myself
and in some parts I disconnected from my
emotions just to protect me in regular
life
and it's a challenge for me to reconnect
to my old emotions that I already had in
circumstances that would help
um do you have any advice
yeah well uh God I have a lot of advice
around that because
um
uh 70 of the time that people in their
waking lives
they live in a very protective State
they live in a state of stress or in a
state of survival in fact it's such a
program that we don't know that we're
doing this we're always
spanning the environment to determine if
it's safe or not and if something
appears out of the predictable or
unknown it alerts us and we move into a
state of arousal and we begin to turn on
the very systems that begin to say
danger threat possible scenario that's
not uh safe
and when that happens we literally begin
to anticipate an outcome
and when we do that we're always
preparing
for what could go wrong
and we begin to create the emotions
ahead of the experience of what happens
if it goes wrong whether it's fear
anxiety worry sadness pain when we do
that unconsciously that's what a program
is
and that becomes the habit
so if you're living in a world where men
have to provide and show a certain
amount of success and be competitive
then you're not going to open your heart
it's not a time to do that it's a time
to survive and thrive in an environment
and yet
um in our work I see men that if they
practice
yeah opening their hearts and it's just
being a child again being a boy again
being curious being wondering being free
being allowing yourself to let go let's
say you've had some pretty rough
experiences in your past
and those experiences cause you to feel
sad and unworthy and guilty
and judgmental
and you've gotten so used to feeling
guilty and unworthy and judgmental that
that's just feels normal to you
and then because you feel kind of
victimized
then you blame people and you complain
and you make excuses and you feel sorry
for yourself and that's your personality
and all of a sudden you say today
I'm not going to do that any longer
because that's the old self
and then you start off your day and it
goes really well for about two hours
and then all of a sudden the moment you
realize that you're no longer making the
same choices as the day before you are
going to feel uncomfortable
it's going to feel unfamiliar
it's going to be uncertain there's going
to be some unpredictability
and we now know that people would rather
hold on to their guilt and unworthiness
than to step into the unknown
because at least they can feel something
and so the moment you stop making the
same choices that you always make get
ready because it's going to be
uncomfortable and that's the moment
you're heading towards the new self
and we call it stepping into the river
of change
but now remember 95 percent of who you
are is your body as the mind
you know you've done something enough
times that your body does it better than
your brain
so you may actually complain
unconsciously because your body does it
all the time
and all of a sudden you say no
complaining
no more blaming no more feeling sorry
for myself no more talking about other
people I'm gonna stop
you know what happens don't you
the body starts sending signals to the
brain
the body's been conditioned that way
and all of a sudden you start hearing
thoughts in your head
that say why don't you start tomorrow
's a better day
this is too hard for me I can't change
something's wrong with me it's my
mother's fault it's my ex-husband's
fault it's my ex-wife's fault I'm this
way because of this event or the most
important one this doesn't feel right
and the moment you respond to that
thought is if it's true
that thought leads to the same Choice
which leads to the same behavior that
creates the same experience that
produces the same emotion and the person
says this feels right
that feels familiar
going from the old self to the new self
stepping into that void stepping into
that uncertainty is the biological the
neurological the chemical the hormonal
genetic death of the old self
and people will say to us well in that
unknown I can't predict my life or my
future
and we always say the same thing to them
the best way to predict your future is
to create it not from the known but from
the unknown
and when you and I get comfortable in
the place of the unknown that's where
the magic happens and it never happens
in the known
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
about the law of attraction Secrets
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there then I'm gonna
feel so great now that well then they're
back to the program waiting for it to
happen for them to feel the emotion
they're believing their outer world has
to change in order for them to feel
better there's there's no